[MUSIC PLAYING]
TEJ KUMAR KARKI: Hello,
my name is Tej Karki.
I'm a visiting scholar in the
MIT-UTM Malaysian Sustainable
Cities Program.
I welcome viewers to watch
this video about the challenges
of urban flooding in Malaysia.
Floods are the third
most destructive disaster
in the world, after
storms and earthquakes.
In Malaysia, floods account
for 90% of natural disasters.
The average annual
costs of flood damage
are over $100 million US.
In this video,
I will show how residents
and local authorities
dealt with floods in Kota Tinggi
town in southern Malaysia,
and what the global community
can learn from this experience.
The key message is that
this video provides
is that the residents
and local authorities
should not only
strengthen their ability
to deal with flood
disasters, but also
communicate with each other
and take joint action.
From December 2006
to January 2007,
huge floods that
would normally be
expected to occur
every 50 years,
occurred twice in Kota Tinggi.
Heavy monsoon rain
poured continuously
for five days in
mid December 2006.
The rain prompted huge
flooding in the area.
Upstream flood
control dams failed
to contain the excess water.
As a result, the downstream
Johor river water levels
rose rapidly and flooded
all of Kota Tinggi.
For one week, the
town was under water.
Two weeks later, the
rain started again
and lasted four days.
Since the soil was already
saturated with water
from the previous
flood, it could not
absorb any more flood water.
As a result, this rain generated
an even deeper and more
widespread flood in the area.
Between the two flood
events, over 5,000 residents
were evacuated.
Fifteen people were killed,
and $44 million US of property
was damaged.
Many town residents did not
receive early warning messages
in time.
The huge unexpected flood
shocked both the town residents
and local authorities.
Some residents
left for shelters,
some were stranded
on roofs, and others
sheltered in tall
buildings near their home.
Those who took refuse in the
houses of their loved ones
were also flooded.
Eventually, they had
to go to shelters.
Many were not able to
protect valuable assets
like cars and furniture.
One resident, who was on a
trip abroad during the flood
incident, lost everything.
Another resident's
downtown boutique shop
went completely underwater.
Those residents who were busy
praying inside their homes
did not anticipate that
the flood would rise
so fast in their front yard.
Those who did not go to
the shelter in the daytime
had difficulty getting
rescued at night.
Most residents were not trained
in how to respond to flooding.
The households did not
discuss flood issues
with their neighbors, and
they acted individually.
The flood victims
rescue needs far
exceeded the ability of the
Kota Tinggi district authority.
The firefighters had
limited resources
to respond to mounting
calls for rescue.
SPEAKER: (Non-English)
TEJ KUMAR KARKI: Most city
transport routes and vehicles
were inundated
causing a disruption
in the supply of basic goods.
Because of the
disruption in the supply,
the local authorities had a hard
time meeting demand for food.
Providing clean water
and better sanitation
were are other challenges.
More importantly,
the town itself
is located in a flood risk area.
It sits largely on a flood
plain near the Johor river
that is often inundated
due to high tides.
Even so, the local zoning map
does not show flood risk areas
in the town.
New housing developments are
now under way in areas that
were heavily inundated in 2006.
Furthermore, most houses
developed in flood risk areas
have low [INAUDIBLE].
Private housing
developers prefer
building low [INAUDIBLE] to
minimize construction costs
and maximize profits.
This development trend
makes the ground floor
vulnerable to any ordinary
flooding in the area.
This goes against the
traditional Malaysian practice
of building houses on stilts.
For cities and towns
in the global south,
the Malaysian experience
reveals three priorities
for flood preparedness--
educating and empowering
local residents,
strengthening the capacity
of local authorities, and
improving local zoning
regulations.
First, the local authorities
should educate and involve
local residents in all
flood related issues.
This would encourage
the residents
to form a neighborhood level
flood prevention community.
Second, the authorities should
establish a reliable flood
warning system.
They should make sure
that firefighters
have enough equipment,
manpower, and advanced training
to respond and rescue.
The firefighters should
work with local residents,
train them, and develop a joint
strategy on coping with floods.
Finally, plenty authorities
should create a zoning map
that shows flood
risk areas in town
and that prohibits
new development
in those risky areas.
They should provide monetary
incentives to residents
to raise their house
floors above the ground.
The authorities should
relocate and resettle residents
living in flood prone
areas to higher ground.
The experiences
presented above showed
that the residents, as
well as local authorities
need to strengthen
their ability to deal
with flood disasters in cities.
However, their strengths
will not be as effective
if they act separately.
Both the city residents
and local authorities
should work together,
talk to each other,
learn from each other,
and act collectively
to find ways to deal
with flood disaster.
[MUSIC PLAYING]